In our first example, you could work 40 hours and earn $400. Let's say you start
a new job that pays a different hourly wage. Now you're going to work 35 hours
and earn $630. At this new job, let's say you worked 35 hours and you earned
$630. How much could you earn working 50 hours? Whenever we saw problems
involving variation we want to set up a proportion. So let's make this really
simple. If I worked one hour, I would earn $10 based on my original example. So
if I work double that amount of time, I would get double the amount of money. I
would earn $20. Notice that if my hours worked increased then my amount of money
also increased. This is so that way these two fractions will be equal. And one
of the biggest things we want to make sure of when solving variation problems is
that we have one fraction involving hours another involving income. We always
want to keep our units the same. Whenever we have direct variation, the first
amount of one unit will be directly across from the first amount of the second
unit. So when I'm filling in this proportion, 35 hours should go here for the
amount of hours worked for one And $630 should go here for the income worked for
1, because if we work 35 hours, we earned $630. So you try solving this one. How
much money could we earn if we worked 50 hours? Be sure you don't include the
dollar sign in your answer. I already have that written for you.